rudy giuliani's manhattan apartment
raided by federal agents today
seven fbi agents carrying out a search
warrant at the former new york city
mayor's home
they seized his electronic devices the
feds have been
focused on giuliani's business dealings
in ukraine during the trump presidency
giuliani's attorney telling fox news his
client quote didn't do
anything wrong and quote that lawyer
also sang and here again i quote
the search warrants involve only one
indication
of an alleged incident of failure to
register as a foreign agent
mayor giuliani has not only denied this
allegation but offered twice
in the past two years through his
attorney bob costello
to demonstrate that it is entirely
untrue
end quote and giuliani's son andrew
giving this statement i'm speaking as a
son
and a concerned american anybody
any american whether you're red or blue
should be extremely
disturbed by what happened here today by
the continued
politicization of the justice department
this is disgusting this is absolutely
absurd
the only piece of evidence that they did
not take up there today
was the only piece of incriminating
evidence that is in there
and it does not belong to my father
it belongs to the current president's
son
that's all i have to say
katie as you just heard from andrew
giuliani that there's this
he he's making this out to be a
political attack on his dad
but rudy giuliani was under
investigation before
president biden came into office jansaki
the press secretary said today there
is no politics involved what do you
think
well i would say that the department of
justice and the fbi have zero
credibility when it comes to pushing
back on allegations of political
targeting you'll remember under the
obama administration where
president joe biden now was the vice
president they went after conservatives
through the irs
the fbi during president trump's first
run for the white house in 2016 was
using information from hillary clinton's
campaign from a foreign spy to open up
and to validate investigations against
people who were working
in the trump campaign so i think they
have a valid argument when they say
we're very concerned here about
political targeting
now that joe biden is in charge
of the the justice department and the
other question is
where's the the equal application of the
law here
when they bring up hunter biden hunter
biden openly worked for a ukrainian gas
company and never registered as a
foreign agent
hunter biden lied on a federal
background check form for
a firearm that's a felony hasn't really
been charged or
looked into as far as we know so there
should be a standard of equality under
the law
and we've seen the fbi and the doj use
their power
to go after political opponents of the
democrats time and time again
so brian uh as we all know rudy giuliani
was the was president trump's personal
lawyer
now this investigation the general
investigation centered on their efforts
to dig up
dirt negative information on then
candidate biden
do you anticipate that this signals
there going to be charges
filed soon against giuliani a couple of
things i mean
we are indeed indicating and he's seeing
andy mccarthy today they say you can't
obtain a search warrant
unless you need to unless investigators
persuaded the judge
that they had sufficient reason to
believe a crime was committed and they
were going to get evidence so after two
hours seven agents and waking him up at
six
uh six in the morning they think they
got something what andrew was referring
to
was uh the laptop of hunter biden why is
the government not curious about the
laptop this has been a
what a two-year investigation into a
laptop that according to the excerpts
i've seen in the new york post
uh it's pretty extraordinary uh it's
pretty extraordinary i don't know how
much
how long you need to study some of those
photos and some of that into
that exchange but it's going to be
interesting they want to focus on
the oligarchs and what he might have
done for the oligarchs in relation to
a investigation for donald trump to find
out what joe biden may have been
involved with or the biden family
within the ukraine so it's back to the
future from two years ago
to go after a lawyer as if there's
nothing else in new york to go after
rudy giuliani as opposed to the years
with the clinton foundation in new york
where no one was curious
where all that money went and i just
wonder if you're on that laptop and you
see something about private
communications
with the president united states if
that's something there that they're
going to follow
are they going to go through the main
artery and then go down the veins in
order to go around the
bend to go get donald trump that's what
i'm uh that's what i think the the focus
is
i think it's all about the former
president
okay so dana you have two of uh
giuliani's associates lev parnus igor
fruman
they have been charged with campaign
finance violations they pled not guilty
they go to trial in october
so if this seems separate this is about
not registering as a foreign agent
what do you make of this well you know i
worked at doj for about a year
in 2001 to 2002 and one of the things i
learned was 101 ways to say no comment
and i think what happens when you have a
situation like this
rudy giuliani seems to have a pretty
good lawyer because giuliani's initial
instinct was to make a statement
at three o'clock do his radio show and
right before that was to take place
they pulled it back and i think that
that is probably smart because even
though you want to try to win a news
cycle
um you have a good lawyer there that's
advising you and i think
the process is going to be slow these
these wheels turn very slowly and
i understand what his son is saying and
and the points about hunter biden
are also well taken uh merrick garland
might have to answer to this um you know
if he's uh called up for testimony but
what i can imagine is that unless
somebody's leaking something uh
there will be no comment out of the
justice department on this um and
probably not from
rudy giuliani himself either
so jesse there when president trump was
impeached the first time
it was on the basis of putting pressure
on the ukrainian president to get
negative information on biden and i
think we're just running in a circle
here or back to that
incident what do you make of this
i think i speak for everybody on the
show when i say this
rudy giuliani is a national treasure
don't disagree i speak for everyone on
the show
when i say this the guy took on the mob
he took on crime
al-qaeda counselor to the president and
now democratic prosecutors want to lock
up a 76-year-old
icon for a lobbying technicality one
because he advised the president that he
should fire a rotten ambassador
you'd have to register to lobby for that
hunter biden advised his dad to fire a
prosecutor
did he register where's the raid on
hunter's house
i bet you find some nasty stuff on that
raid
and one did rudy giuliani steal any
money did he hurt anybody
did he engage in treason no
none of that happened this is something
he was talking to the federal
prosecutors for
months about and they say we'll give you
what you want
but we're not turning over private
communications between rudy and the
president
that's attorney-client privilege and
that's sacred
everybody should respect that so what
the prosecutors do they just
raided the guy's house you're not
disturbed by the pattern that two trump
lawyers
have their homes rated the campaign
manager has his home rated another
confidant has his own rate you're not
disturbed by that pattern
the fact that democrat prosecutors are
waging political warfare
for the benefit of the democratic party
just to purge
trump because he challenged the system
i mean that should scare everybody juan
this is a this is a
thin predicate and everybody knows it
okay we heard you we hear you jesse